if you want to do great things you need
to be surrounded by greatness so put
this on in the background and get ready
for some great ideas from some great
people we think we ain't about how hard
you how do you succeed if you don't try
the time is now to be great you gotta
love it you gotta have a passion you
really can make what you want I played a
lot of sports when I was younger and I
settled on soccer because the 99 would
seem really motivated me my dad would go
out on the soccer field with me every
day and it pushed myself in a good way
and motivated me to be the best soccer
was just my thing and I wanted to make
it to the u.s. national team my favorite
goal was against Italy I scored in
probably the 93rd minute and I think
that's one of the best parts of my game
is my finishing
everyone has their talent but it's what
you do with that talent to make it great
boy this is the first time in years here
this offer amendments is hard to
remember an old computer language I not
only designed this every little metal
trace that you see on here I strapped on
onto a drafting table and I built this
whole board myself because I wanted the
chips in the ultimate perfect position I
worked for a couple of weeks every night
till about 4:00 in the morning laying
out the little things on a big drafting
table that would eventually become this
board and when I got done I realized I
had to drill eight holes in the board
and I said you know what if I had only
designed it a little bit differently
then I would have only had five holes I
tore apart my entire design and for
another two weeks every night till 4:00
in the morning to get it just that
perfect with only five holes so you
would never see the three missin it had
to be that artistically perfect to me
because it represents yourself when you
do something when you do a great design
the other great secret is that we're
good at lifelong learning
Warren is so much better in some ways in
his 70s and 80s and he was younger that
it's almost awesome if you keep learning
all the time you have a huge advantage
and we both just like it and we have a
wonderful group of friends really one
from whom we can learn a lot someone
asked him what's the most difficult
thing about going to the moon
and he says the will to do it the
engineering is just calculations but the
decision and the will in the courage to
try to do it is the most difficult
hurdle a man's reach should exceed his
grasp it's just life is a carrousel life
is a bowl of cherries I don't know it's
it's life is short and you just got a
play dance experiment fail succeed learn
give I'm not worried about my future
about what I'm gonna do in 10 years
after soccer it's about right now you
know how I can contribute to the team
success how I can make sure that you
know I'm physically mentally ready for
each game so it's it's really just
taking it day by day and knowing that
you know the future is so uncertain you
just need to be happy where you are
right now and just have a positive
outlook on it my tips are don't
necessarily think that you have to have
the homerun and the huge Apple computer
on your first start I spent a long time
in my life with skills just building
little devices for fun for fun is one of
the key things cuz that drives you to
think and think and think and make it
better and better and better than you
ever would if you're doing it for a
company build things at first for
yourself that you would want if you're
gonna build a retail or a real estate
business online well if you're not in
the real estate business you're not
gonna really think about it the right
way you're building it for other people
that's what I say is wrong you should be
building it for yourself and if you're
not building it for yourself you better
have a tight partnership with somebody
that is that absolutely wants it for
themselves because they're gonna want it
to be so perfect and so right and not
confusing and make it all the beauty
into the product the idea that the
safest way to try and get what you want
is to try and deserve what you want it's
such a simple idea that's the golden
rule so to speak you you want to deliver
to the world what you would buy if you
were on the other
there is no ethos in my opinion that
it's better for any lawyer or any other
person to have by and large the people
who've had this ethos when in life and
they don't win just money just honors
and emollient months they win the
respect the deserve trust of the people
they deal with and there is huge
pleasure in life to be obtained from
getting deserved trust and so and the
way to get it is to deliver what you'd
want to buy if the circumstances were
reversed we are known for trying new
things even though we have a tough
schedule we did an airplane that we that
the customer wanted it flying within I
think is eight and a half months and we
elected on our own to try a totally new
manufacturing method for the wings and
tail surfaces and control surfaces
something that hadn't been done before
something that may not work something
that was really exciting and interesting
and if it did work its breakthrough
stuff in life it's like you know follow
your bliss if you're following a path
that is pleasurable to you it's much
easier it's flows it's there's a life
behind the eyes you know there's there's
a shine within it's beyond it's it's not
just work it's it's a joyous experience
it's a you long for that so in the
morning I get a good night's sleep and
then in the mornings I try and get out
here on alkine this
kind of walk around it's just a really
beautiful place to kind of start your
morning and have a positive mentality
going into your day yoga definitely fits
into my life in terms of separation it's
great just to have that sense of feeling
at ease with yourself stretching is a
huge part of soccer and making sure that
you know you're pretty flexible and I
just love the feeling of kind of being
alone a little bit and being able to
take my mind off the soccer but at the
same time the reason I go to yoga is to
help me succeed in soccer I was so
stunned because I have very dramatic
memories of where I was when the Beatles
were on Ed Sullivan when I heard that
JFK had been shot and this on you'll
never get this memory out of my head
just where I was just getting a phone
call from a reporter and they just said
have you heard the news and I instantly
knew what that meant
and that was just a total shock like
what do you say it's like the world lost
a John Lennon I mean Steve was clearly
the most outstanding business thinker
and almost everybody who's high up in
the technology business recognized that
that somehow he had the ability to think
out new ways of doing things not just
ways to improve what we have do a better
version of something but do it in a
totally different way that the world
would swing towards and then I think
back to just all the times we had
together very very good times that you
have when you're young you know and
playing around with the systems and
Little Miss behavior and doing
interesting things and and then he was
always thinking about certain technology
the early products that got developed
the building parts what those might lead
to in our future and he was always
pushing me as an engineer could you
possibly have this someday could you
possibly have that someday yes yes yes I
could thinking no it's way way off but
eventually we all did we went into the
garage when we were two young people
with no money you have to work out of
your home we had jobs on the side we had
nobody that could loan us money we had
no business experience we're like a
million young people who are so excited
about the future they might have some
day in business making something just
out of their ideas that's what we work
over and over and over all the products
of Apple from you know iPhones and iPads
iPods these were just unbelievable life
changers and almost everyone who heads
the technology company looks at Steve
Jobs is where did he get the ideas to do
it the right way we were just the lucky
partnership he was lucky to have me in
the beginning but I am much you know
incredibly lucky to him for everything
in my life he gets a reputation for
being a strong leader and being brash
but to me he was just always so kind
such a good friend and I'm just gonna
miss him
one of these guys at the burger beating
from one of the foreign publications
said quite a couple of guys in a little
place in Omaha do so much better than
all these powerful minds and great
institutions and I said well I think
Warren and I know the edge of our
competency better than other people do
and that's humility and the umbrella
sense that is a very important thing to
know I say over and over again it's not
a competency if you don't know the edge
of it you were a disaster if you don't
know the edge of your own competency
where I'm frequently says I'd rather
deal with the guy with an IQ of 130 who
thinks it's 125 not guy with an IQ of
180 the things that's 200 that second
guy will kill you and and so it is very
important to know the edge of your own
competency our first astronaut Alan
Shepard who flew us am orbital flight
followed Gagarin by only three weeks
after Shepards flight it took only
seven-and-a-half years for us to launch
Apollo 8 to go out and orbit the moon
they went to the moon on the very first
manned flight of the big Saturn 5 now
can you imagine today NASA developing a
brand-new huge big advanced rocket and
the first time people fly on it they go
to the moon or they go somewhere we've
never been before that puts in
perspective the kind of risks that we
that we were taking and those who put
themselves in a position to take
enormous risks are those that have
breakthroughs and those that that have
research results as I get older I just
thought too many people said to me how
could you not sing in public like we as
your fans really want to
hear you and see you live and I thought
I owe this to them then maybe I owe it
to myself to to build up the courage to
try it again
because it's not about perfection as you
know you know this could happen your
voice could go flat under them and there
is a certain excitement to that and a
certain acceptance again of you know
imperfections I didn't expect when I
sprained my ankle back in October late
October that it would come to this and
that was the hardest part for me it was
kind of doubting myself like well you
know why didn't I
why didn't I take it easier why didn't I
kind of pull myself out of training or
out of the game but you can't look back
you kind of just need to look forward it
was it was definitely hard but I feel
like now that I'm actually seeing
improvement we just got a muraayn it
kind of helps me a little bit mentally
to be able to do bike a little bit to be
able to swim I wasn't able to do
anything on crutches so now knowing that
there's improvement I'm able to do some
stuff I feel a lot more I guess happy
your actions you should always feel in
life and in your jobs your actions are
somehow have a good purpose behind them
they better the world in some way don't
ever do something just because it's an
assignment you better believe that it's
doing it there is some in the end goal
that is good for the world almost every
new invention and computer and all came
about from those ideals I mean I really
wanted to help the world communicate so
much you know other people inspired me
into a revolution I want to be a part of
changing things want to be a part of
better education want be a part of the
young person having so much mastery over
technology and be able to do things they
never could before
those were the goods that were pushing
me it was almost almost without those
goods I wouldn't even designed a
computer it's not my nature when you get
little surprises as a result of human
nature just spend much time feeling
betrayed I always want to just put my
head down on it just so I don't allow
myself to spend much time ever with any
feelings of betrayal so you're asking
the wrong person because if I if some
flickering idea like that came to me
get rid of it quickly I don't like any
feeling of being victimized I think
that's a counterproductive way to think
as a human being and I am NOT a victim a
survivor
I believe that confidence and nonsense
is a major factor and the reason is
think of the most important breakthrough
that you can think of go back before it
was recognized as a breakthrough and the
populace normally would consider well
that's nonsense that's nonsensical and
all of a sudden when it really is
recognized as a true breakthrough then
of course oh yeah that's really cool but
what people forget is it's nonsense
before well what that means that's why
the weird folk have the breakthroughs
because they have confidence in nonsense
if it's nonsensical and you say well I'm
not gonna try to do that it didn't make
sense you're not gonna have a
breakthrough the guy who is silly enough
to think that hey I'll try that even
though it's nonsense he's the guy that's
gonna have the breakthrough so try
things that you don't think will work if
you think they'll work you're not doing
research anyway my mother had a great
voice not like mine not like my sisters
not like my son a high soprano voice but
like a bird I mean really beautiful but
I used to say mom you know why didn't
you try to get a career as a singer no
she said she was too shy she couldn't do
it and I'm basically shy too but there
that that makes the difference you know
how do you succeed if you don't try
before every game the key to my
preparation is consistency I really
think that every athlete is a little bit
superstitious and if an athlete tells
you otherwise I think they're lying so
yes I do a couple of things I definitely
put on my right sock before my left sock
and I like to take a nap at the same
time and eat the same things and then
right before the game I like to do a lot
of mental visualization so I'll go in a
locker and just put on headphones and
just imagine myself in the game everyone
everyone likes to talk about failures
you know but the main thing is you might
have a lot of little small steps every
one of those step
seem to not take you anywhere in money
it didn't get you much more money it
didn't get any money but you know you're
kind of proud you show them off to
friends even your mind was increasing
your methods of coming up with better
solutions was increasing you not only
have to now read a book on how things
are done you can write the book and
that's called creativity you create new
things yourself so always try to here's
the biggest key I can give to anybody in
the world that if you're kind of smart
and you're working on some project maybe
it's software maybe it's hardware try to
think of the end you complete it you
know enough to complete it don't stop
there say how can I make it perfect
almost better than any other human being
would can I shorten the code can i redo
it a little cleaner structure give
yourself some of those reduce and when
you're young you'll put in a lot more
than eight hours a day I listened in law
school when some wag said a legal mind
is a mind that when two things are all
twisted up together and interacting it's
feasible to think responsibly about one
thing and not the other well I could see
from that one sentence that that was
perfectly ridiculous and it pushed me
further into my natural drift which was
into learning all the big ideas and all
the big disciplines so I wouldn't be a
perfect damn fool who was trying to
think about one aspect of something that
couldn't be removed from the totality of
the situation in a constructive fashion
and what I know that since the really
big ideas carried 95% of the freight it
wasn't at all hard for me to pick up all
the big ideas in all the disciplines and
make them a standard part of my mental
routines once you have the ideas of
course they're no good if you don't
practice you don't practice you lose it
so I went through life constantly
practicing this Malo disciplinary
approach well I can't tell you what
that's done for me
if it's it's it's made life more fun
it's made me more constructive it's made
me more helpful to others it's made me
enormous ly rich you name it that
attitude really helps you're gonna have
failures if you try hard stuff if you go
out and try to build a better seaplane
and your goal is to go 12 knots faster
you're probably not gonna fail you may
fail because it only goes 4 knots faster
but it's not gonna be a disaster failure
but if you go out and try something that
that is holy crap can you really do that
and it fails it is a failure the truth
is I think for years I thought well I
don't want to disappoint people you know
it's like it's like you have this thing
for me well if you meet me you know will
you be disappointed will destroy the
mystique now as you get older you and
when you accept your own imperfections
there's a there's a warmth to that
that's like the Indian sowing and the
flaw in the blanket you know that it
shouldn't be perfect so I really can't
make a mistake because if I accept my
flaws then you will accept my flaws
exactly when people ask me how I balance
non soccer stuff that thing's off the
field I you know I think it just I've
been more confident in the last couple
of years with the decisions I make and
opportunities that are given and
decisions whether to go through with it
or not you know if it's authentic to Who
I am and you know whether it's a company
I'm representing or whether it's an
event
- photoshoot that I've been asked to do
I think it's you know it's just weighing
all of the things and making sure that
nothing is standing in the way of what I
do best and what I'm here for
believe in yourself you don't have to
win arguments you don't have to prove to
somebody else that you're right if you
believe you're right everybody'll say no
it's not done this way you'll never make
money at it but you believe in it that's
all that's what matters you know and you
got to follow what's in your heart and
but the second piece of advice is how
far you go in life is usually I was
taught this when I was young and I
believe it
it's how well-liked you are by the
people you work with that will determine
how far you go up organization chart
ladders and the like so be nice to
people don't be cutting them down you
know don't be rude and all that stuff
you know it's just my philosophy we have
to deal on things that were capable of
understanding and then once we're over
that filter we have to have a business
with some intrinsic characteristics that
give it a durable competitive advantage
and then of course we would vastly
prefer a management in place with a lot
of integrity and talent and finally no
matter how wonderful it is it's not
worth an infinite price so we have to
have a price that makes sense and gives
a margin of safety considering the
natural vicissitudes of life that's a
very simple set of ideas and the reason
that our ideas have not spread faster is
they're too simple the professional
classes can't justify their existence if
that's all I have to say and I feel very
strongly that it's not good enough for
us to have generations of kids that
think that it's OK to look forward to a
better version of a cell phone with a
video in it they need to look forward to
exploration and you look forward to
colonization they need to look for
two breakthroughs they need to we need
to inspire them because they need to
lead us and help us survive in the
future music is is transporting music
elevates life you know music is larger
than life you know when you're when you
have certain emotions that are larger
than life you want to sing you want to
you want to express it in a larger way
music is so powerful to the soul it's so
rich and being able to identify with
feelings
music can transport so it's very strong
I think there's no secret to success I
mean I think Abbey definitely hit the
nail on the head it's it's all about
hard work it's all about going out there
and and practicing more than your
opponent than your teammates it's it's
about mentally preparing every single
day it's about not slacking off putting
in that time and work and you could tell
from Abby that she is put in that work
and that's I think the reason that she
is so so successful but at the end of
the day end of the day there is no there
is no secret to why we are so successful
the talents that you have you're
learning so many formulas how to connect
things how to build devices the main
thing is why would you go through an
education learning how to design and
create new things and then go out and
just try to copy what exists always try
to think for yourself and think out
better things and were there before even
don't be afraid to go in different ways
shai engineers I think you have a huge
advantage when you come I always want to
have an instant answer to everything you
don't sit back and reflect and think out
the best working solution taking
everything into account spend a lot of
time on your own call it dream time
maybe when you're just alone in a quiet
room nobody else with you falling asleep
and and really imagine the limits of
where you can go
don't start building something until
you've gone very far and you know that
it's you thought something out very well
that's ahead of what other people are
doing try to imagine yourself as the
best engineer in the world every one of
you try to think a little trick you can
do in your design could I do one thing
different a do something that would make
me better that other engineers wouldn't
do and and also that's basically a
pursuit of excellence and believe in
your own ideas even if other people are
saying no that's not how it's done it's
too different well those very different
things are what are disruptive and they
wind up putting other companies out of
business and really changing our life
and you're young engineer in college
weirded companies like Yahoo and Google
and Apple and Facebook and and you know
so many others where did they come from
they came from young people soft you
know young people dropping out of
college or just out of college we have
this system where we translate very
trustworthy people and give them
enormous trust and as they practice that
trust they get more confirmed and being
trustworthy and eventually we've got
this seamless web of trust which is
incredibly efficient and very useful and
by the way this is not just my doctrine
there's a doctor and economics it tries
to explain why firms come into existence
and firms come into existence because a
lot of people who trust one another
operating within a firm are more
efficient than they would be if they
were a bunch of independent proprietors
what I try to encourage people to do is
to have a breakthrough by finding a way
to do it more simply and even if the
real simple one has a chance of not
working because it's too simple
well try it anyway because in trying it
sometimes you'll stumble on to a
solution on why it wouldn't work and now
you've really had a big gain now you
have a simple thing that does work and
that's that's the real the real
challenge now you can always make
something work by adding complexity but
you can never make something affordable
by
adding complexity you had a lot of
people say you were never gonna make it
beside your mom yeah and what did you
think in your head when they'd say that
I thought they were crazy same thing
with me that's what I just know I mean I
thought I knew their what they what
meant I I knew why they thought that but
isn't that funny that that's within
enormous insecurity and doubt was a kind
of knowing and knowing that you know if
I stick to my guns and I tell the truth
and I I will be there I don't know I
never thought about it that much it was
something so deep I guess that uh I tell
people some people ask me another do you
think I should be an actress and and I
say boy if you have to think about it
don't be it I think most forwards like
to play under pressure or I'll see you
when it play the forward position but I
do like that pressure and sometimes you
don't always succeed and that's okay and
as a forward you have to find that
balance I mean you're gonna shoot five
times and maybe you'll score once maybe
you won't you know maybe you'll get
three goals out of three shots so it's a
little unpredictable and you just kind
of got to go with it and have confidence
in yourself these days entrepreneurship
is taught as courses in all the colleges
and usually it's a business level course
so you've got all these business guys
that oh my gosh if I write some ideas
down on paper that's how you go about it
starting the company and all right my
principle is know so many people in
Silicon Valley got used to write ideas
down on paper and then try to get some
money trying some might try to get some
money like we can just buy the
engineering for it no I like the type of
entrepreneurship that has actually
created working models here is an
example of something that works the way
we want it and we built it and we've got
the the talented the talented technical
people that know how to do it and I
think it should get to that phase and so
the Entrepreneurship it's a combination
of the business and the technical doers
the technology people I'm really
following a very key idea of the
greatest lawyer of antiquity Marcus tell
us Cicero and Cicero is famous for
saying a man who doesn't know what
happened before he's born goes through
life like a child that is a very correct
idea of Cicero's and he's right to
ridicule somebody so foolish is not to
know what happened before he was born
but if you generalize Cicero as I think
one should there are all these other
things that you should know in addition
to history and those other things are
the big ideas and all the other
disciplines and it doesn't help you just
to know them enough so you could prattle
them back on an exam and get an A you
have to learn these things in such a way
with their mental latticework in your
head and you automatically use them for
the rest of your life if you do that I
solemnly promise you that one day you'll
be walking down the street and look to
your right and left you'll think my
heavenly days I'm now one of the few
most competent people of my whole age
cohort I think breakthroughs occur not
when everybody's doing fine and when
you're when your priority is to make
everyone equally happy you don't have
breakthroughs then that's monotony and
that can lead to monotony in it and it
can lead even to your ability to survive
but you have breakthroughs either during
or after crises when you have really bad
times we're creative when we're
threatened now I can direct people know
I can do it now I can write songs people
know I can write songs I don't need to
do that anymore
i I do bore myself a lot you know I have
to go on and it's not conquer I don't
know I'd use the word conquer it's it's
expanding one's horizon you know it's
it's trying something new
it's risking failure it's even that's
exciting to me you know I wanted to
be an Olympic gold medalist since the
since I was seven years old so but that
was a dream role models are who my role
model is I mean I definitely looked up
to Christine Willy Mia Hamm Abbi even in
high school and getting on the national
team but I feel like I always wanted to
kind of make my parents proud and they
really like the two people that came to
every single game and just where my
biggest fans so but it's things like
knowing who you are inside who you are
and believe it in that person and
remember the through life and saying
today it's a good person I am and I have
some good values and a good hand on my
shoulders and I don't want to be
corrupted by the successes I'm gonna
have in life and in business I don't
want to be corrupted and going different
ways if I make a lot of money I still
want to be that good pure human who
thinks well like I said don't don't set
yourself up for those frowns you know
and you don't always have to win every
single argument you can think your way
and believe your thoughts are good in
your own brain and somebody else doesn't
agree with you it's okay
they just think a different way there's
no need to look at the world of oh we've
all got to be in competition it's my way
everyone has to be just like me or
they're no good they have to use my
computer then to go to my school they
have to be my country you know they have
to do things my way that's not the way
the things be very open to a lot of
different people have differences and we
can all still see each other as good and
we get along a lot better and have a lot
more peace that way acceptance of others
is the key warning I have not made our
way in life by making successful
macroeconomic predictions and betting on
our conclusions our system is to swim as
confidently as we can and sometimes the
tide will be with us and sometimes it
will be against us but by and large we
don't much bother with trying to predict
the tides because we plan to play for
the game for a long time I recommend to
all of you exactly the same attitude
it's kind of a snare and a delusion to
outguess macroeconomic cycles very few
people do it successfully and some of
them do it by accident and the game is
that tough
why not adopt the other system of
swimming as competently as you can and
figuring that over a long life you'll
have your share of good times and bad
tides I think the world of aviation will
gain from me mostly inspiration the fact
that a few people literally in a garage
or a small shop built an airplane that
doubled an absolute distance record flew
all the way around the world flew
through all this weather and came back
safely
the fact that that was done
all-composite without mixing metals
without solving all these stupid
problems that the engineers made for
themselves that will provide the
inspiration
it can be done we're gonna do it we'll
stick our necks out I knew how the
Wright brothers felt when they came upon
these things and and had success you see
actually you have to be thankful for
people like that because in a way they
gave you more courage that gave you more
energy a more and more of a sense of
your own destiny it's true
I thank my mother actually for not
believing in me because I really set out
to prove to her that I that she was
wrong and that I I could make something
of my life you know as an actress you
know it's not what I wanted them to see
I just wanted them to feel the passion
and I wanted them to to grow that
passion because this is exactly what I
dreamed of when I was a young kid when I
was watching you this is what I dreamed
of you're gonna make me cry stop just a
dream big dreams you have his life about
how much you've done with technology how
much you've achieved how much money you
made in your life or is life about how
many times you laughed compared to
smiled I would rather have a happier
life and sure if getting success in
business is what makes me happy that's
fine but I really believe that you know
some kind of enjoyment aspect should go
through especially all learning and all
work now I was an engineer the work is
hard it's intense
you work late hours at night sometimes
trying to solve a problem you know and
you just it's so hard to get there and
you finally crack through and that's
sort of a relief but you know what when
you're working that hard all day long
you need those little jokes with your
friends you need the lunch time where
you sit down and chat is such a big part
of your life
life will have terrible blows in
horrible blows unfair blows doesn't
matter
and some people recover and others don't
and and their I think the attitude of
epictetus is the best he thought that
every missed chance in life was an
opportunity to behave well every miss
chance in life was an opportunity to
learn something and your duty was not to
be submerged in self-pity but to utilize
the terrible blow and I construct a
fashion was one thing and that was a
passion that I saw in your eyes for the
outcome and I knew you would stick with
it because I knew that passion with
genja when you go out of the venture
capital or whatever you're looking for
people who have a passion for money but
you have a passion for space life and I
think that's the difference
I am proud to say I am but there is no
such thing as perfection and I found
that out when I was 15 years old I wrote
it in my journal that perfection is
imperfection so it has that humanity a
human quality otherwise it's too cold
right you could just strive for
perfection better word is excellent
strive for excellence thank you guys so
much for watching let us know what you
thought about this in the comments below
go and do something great today and
continue to believe they're playing